[Music]
in moon reader news can read that though
could you submitted by L ma there is an
AI system that could warn you if your
partner is having a happy day a bad day
oh I did it on purpose
Wow I need a no-no therefore I don't
have to tell when the girl is having a
bad day house with their [ __ ] having a
bad day was they never had bad days
we're always good mood but is it because
I'm a guy has a bad day we actually
could tell you we're having a bad day
don't be surprised David not every man
is like kebab and I feel like 90% of
times like that though well a good day
until we realized we had about there
how about word when I remember him to
like realize like oh yeah know what I'm
there I think I'm having a good day
until I yell at somebody and I go oh I
had a bad day no I shot someone maybe
you can benefit from this so researchers
at USC University of Southern California
hey Jack down the street mm-hm
I see you USC Trojan condom yes oh they
say that there is new technology that
can that they've developed where it can
let you know if your partner is having a
bad day and give you like a heads up so
you can know how to respond to them and
also you're telling your partner like
hey maybe you should like meditate cool
down before you interact with your
partners is a sense that there's gonna
be conflict arising oh yeah
that's tight I think this is cool
but at the same time I'm somebody who it
doesn't like this why because you are
trying to fix problems in a relationship
through this when you should be able to
do that through communicating with
somebody rather than relying on this
like a crystal ball baby
I think this could benefit people that
don't realize that they're in a certain
mood but that's funny
yeah yeah like Jo I'm perfectly cut out
all time for you to learn that as well a
butler's make an alert bathroom I think
what's gonna happen with you she's gonna
figure too bad well I'm glad more yeah
did you believe that mood rings actually
learn yep Alice [ __ ] dog because like
to me like what I wanted to is a warmer
polish [ __ ] that should change his cry I
didn't realize that because like well
when did you would not when did you
realize that we look 85 no sounds like
middle school I was an elementary girl
with a pharmacy I was never exposed to
mood rings until like I want to wear to
my uncle shelf cause he sold a whole
bunch of dresses and like random
necessities you never went to the
Science Center
they always got movies in the gift shop
no I didn't know in the bush in the book
star the book shop thing what is it book
fair no no no you put on the mood ring
at eighth grade yeah I mean it was just
like it just stayed blue the whole time
in my damn you my - oh I didn't get it
it's red cuz you're warm and it follows
your parents in my gun my tattoo stupid
[ __ ] you she's going to figure it out
I know I don't know the technology
behind it on them but it kind of makes
sense because if you're hot and horny
gets all red and [ __ ] and in the girls
like who I knew it
yeah I remember being in elementary
school - and we turned green and I'm
like I don't feel greedy right now I
don't want anything - I remember it me
me wonder why people need stuff like
this like this is stuff that you work on
and in a relationship these beautiful
reminder that you got a like if
feelers isn't the first thing that comes
to your mind like someone like me will
always think that it's like a physical
thing like oh I'm just I'm just uh it's
because I'm constipated so I'm cranky so
whatever I don't know but then this
makes me go oh yeah I have to pay
attention because it's not the same
person I'm talking to like we just
learned about PMS we just learned that
don't actually yeah yeah so when I first
read it read this story I immediately
thought of you
oh you guys always saying like you know
you need you need a center something to
tell your memory or I like that because
my mind is different we just tells me
hey PMS week is coming okay everything
you say is a lie to me cause the things
that you hate that things that you
whatever everything a lie because it's
always going to change when you're right
back to your normal self because see but
you see what happened there
they solved it because we communicated
yeah but what if Merrill forgets to tell
you it's PMS week she doesn't forget
anymore we hadn't thought about that in
a very long time because now I just know
if she if I look at her and she goes why
do you have to do that I'm like what she
will breathe I'm like oh you're PMSing
you [ __ ] I have to I agree with David I
do see the immediate the immediate
benefits and I think like couples at um
aren't communicating very well and they
don't feel each other very well I think
could definitely benefit them it's
definitely a tool but I think it needs
to be kind of like like NicoDerm CQ
where you have to be able to like wean
off of it because if it becomes the
crutch of the relationship Dania you're
not just like let's say you go on
vacation right for two weeks and forget
to bring nothing you're [ __ ]
so I think communication like we got to
learn how to be human beings and we have
to use that technology help us but it
can't replace us yeah yeah it's pretty
high degree because even was like mellow
just recently I mean we got into an
argument but the reason why we got into
an argument there's been a very long
time since we've butted heads is she
knew that mentioning this to me was
gonna piss me off because it was so
ridiculous but she had to do it in order
for us for her to move on and not think
about it so with her she communicated
something to me even though she knew the
consequences of how angry I would get
and I did get my blue the [ __ ] up
because pretty [ __ ] ridiculous but
you got it out the way and that's like
her kind of like she understood me very
well she goes this is very frivolous
it's stupid but I can't continue my date
until I bring it up with a minute fight
with him about it so we did that I think
it's good for the starts conversation
oh I didn't realize we're in the bad
mood
let me approach it in a more nurturing
way versus why being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
crazy-ass [ __ ] I'm not you're in
November yeah but then if you go oh [ __ ]
I put on my nurse Joe outfit on all
right
I'm feeling a baby mm-hmm I got a look
at her as like she's a three year old
baby
what if there's a glitch in the system
and then you I'm I don't know why I'm
picturing like a thumb at like kind of
like a radar gun you just like zapping
it tells you ain't bad nerd [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it could be applicable to mention it
both what if it starts arguments because
nothing was even wrong - you like baboo
baboo
what will [ __ ] you always in a bad mood
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah well exam it so
it's this algorithm and what it's doing
it's gathering data from wearables
mobile phones and sensors placed on the
body of the participants that were not
possession on every morning come on all
these [ __ ] electrodes no that only
came up with it yeah this is for like
specifically with these researchers so
I'm not sure what they're planning on
doing in the future like for it to be
accessible for us all but this is just
specific to this research and so what
they did is they collected body
temperature heart activity sweat audio
recordings assessment of language
content and vocal intensity and they
discovered that this algorithm was able
to detect conflict episodes with 86
percent accuracy and so they're saying
so this was based on like the
participants hourly self-report and then
also like whenever conflict would occur
so they they were just monitoring
conflict episodes
among these couple these couples that
were participating in this research mmm
that's great so we just analyst data can
be can develop like early intervention
of like upcoming conflict episodes but I
will say like you know complex or like
arguing is healthy and original oh
you're as long as it's not like
destructive exactly as long as I'm not
destructive oh its destructive all right
now they're saying like arguing once a
week is it's a secret to a strong and
happy Union well I do more than that so
it's even more stronger relation is not
abusive I know anything yeah so you
can't arguments once a week that just
I'm tiring I'm not normal though
that is pretty no no depends on what
kind of argument which kind of I say
it's like is it those ones that's like
what do you want to eat I don't know
what do you want to be I don't know can
we eat this not whatever you want but
you say whatever I want but how come BK
is well I love that river left I'd like
that
yes exactly Wow a song of a forest so
there's that kind of argument or there's
like there's no argument II so what kind
of may we talk about I think it's more
of the like friend a [ __ ] put the
milk back in the mat and the
refrigerator storage place you [ __ ] you
see that's that's better I can't I can't
do the whole arguing all the time being
now like it's like I just had like a net
like this an epiphany like a few months
ago it's like I just cannot have it like
it you can argue with me about stuff
that's inherently affecting our
relationship but if you are going to
pick fights about stuff that honestly
you could solve on your own that doesn't
require you to disrupt like what we have
I cannot stand for it like it's just
frivolous it's dumb and I'm not saying
like in the sense of like if we argue
micro emotions by for example that
argument that what's privileged but her
emotions had to be met so it's not
stupid I mean it's dumb but she had to
do that to get it out the way that's
okay but if I'm with somebody or you're
around people that just want to nitpick
things like that I gotta cut you the
[ __ ] out because it I cannot waste my
energy on that [ __ ] so that to me it's
like that's somebody who is just who
likes to be combative like they're
searching for things to find that's
wrong so if you can't be satisfied with
like like just like the status quo and
learn to build on that then you're a
[ __ ] waste of my time and you know
I'm a waste of your time too I can't
deal with it like it now it's stress
because anxiety now
like so let's say like we're having or
chatting or something right
and then your your keyboard I don't know
[ __ ] up and I'm like there's a weird
cell and you'll come back at me like
well I didn't do anything to it it's
like my stupid people come at people
like that all the time yeah those people
like get the [ __ ] out my life like they
feel like they're trying to get under
their skin so yeah what everything is an
attack like on them hate people like
that it's so [ __ ] about I can't do it
you know I wish no I wish you could just
smell each other's but this is my god oh
my god dogs like daylight you know
bigger [ __ ] out you just go
you smell happy and they play or you go
to a dog park oh [ __ ] [ __ ] bold and
they just run off and we can smell each
other's butt and then we could figure
each other out it'd be happy we could
play that's this this algorithm I know
but now you got to have this [ __ ]
device and you gotta [ __ ] put all
these electrodes on a [ __ ] muscles all
day before you can figure [ __ ] I like
Tron and [ __ ] yeah all I want to be able
to do is just be like oh happy or sad
and use like get to the point dogs are
actually highly emotionally
intelligently emotional yes but they
also don't hold grudges oh that's right
das get home you know why dogs [ __ ]
shake because they sink it away yeah
that's all they need they do that and
whatever bad feelings they were feeling
it's gone on one second a lot of animals
do that that's that's how quickly you
know [ __ ] birds - yeah our emotional
recovery is a long time I got to be
getting up there he asked about your
five you feel bad for like the next
couple hours maybe even a day maybe in a
week and you're like block or stone
still get those will go I [ __ ] it I try
to do anymore you know oh yeah just call
you a wiggly man yeah I try I kind of
shake it off all the time it doesn't
work oh really then I just have a
visually Asian egg hello a lot of people
do you want to contact me and everybody
else you see go ahead and check the
description box below and follow our
social medias Instagram and Twitter for
more videos click up there baby
[Music]